how's it going brother - actually yeah
you know what that's my name whoa whoa
whoa daily news renowned inventor Peter
creates the world's first jet pack
welcome to power pilot ear this game
looks hilarious I'm so excited to check
it out let's start off with the part
okay all right we got our first quest
here land on the first bench okay I can
do this
nailed it you're going up now where am I
going
okay okay oh no come on I'll land on the
bench yeah did I do it oh all right
there we go
god damn it it's this is impossible
come on I'm still alive damn it listen
it's what you care it listen this is
what you hear and listen next Oh give it
to you my god yes yes fabulous land on
the crease now then don't you dare even
say that I'm bad at this game it look it
looks so easy but it's oh my god what
are you doing
whoever invented the jetpack obviously
didn't do it right
oh [ __ ] man the [ __ ] beautiful
what is this stay in the air for at
least ten second two seconds
[ __ ] yes do a backflip then land are you
kidding I was so close
[Music]
I don't know what I'm doing with my
laugh bros I'm just enjoying the jetpack
laughs come on come on steady steady
jetpack yeah [ __ ] I got a hot giant hot
dog in my face oh god oh god we got this
we got this no problem to space bros to
space come on
did I do it no come on please it counts
yeah yeah go jetpack go make your dreams
come true jetpack I will be laying here
meanwhile fly above the clouds in land a
problem no problem bro so look at this
[ __ ] I'll do a front-flip even if I have
to mail it I wanted to learn like that
back out
[Music]
Oh shucks our city with us inspiring
jetpack stones I knew you can change
people's heart with front-flip rose I've
said this so many times do you remember
the happy wheels days I've been all
about the front flips and you burst
black hurry doesn't even know what a
front flip is and [ __ ] that's five years
ago oh my god
comment about my hair too and say that
it's nice thank you
oh my god oh my god no problem yep no
problem no problem it out got this [ __ ]
obviously yep no problem problem Wow
hope you enjoyed in this video I had a
lot of fun playing it's a fun little
game so if you want to check it out
yourself I'll leave a link to in the
description or you can just search pilot
here on a voice that's probably you know
I'm too lazy to link live your life be
free to do what you want to do but
especially you need to like this video
thank you bro so much watching i'll see
in the next one as always stay awesome
[Music]
this is the greatest game of all time
but in sweetest music in this game oh my
[ __ ] god